hey guys Pete here today I'm going to do
another Ozark Season three video I'm
gonna talk about the questions I have
after letting the events of season three
set in and what I hope we'll get answers
to in season four at the time of writing
this Netflix hasn't made an official
announcement about green lighting a
fourth season of Ozark but I expect that
they'll do that in the next couple of
weeks
a quick spoiler warning just in case if
you haven't watched the entire Ozark
series through the series three finale
this video will spoil it for you go
watch it now to get caught up and then
please come back to watch this and join
the conversation in the comments after
that the bird family Marty Wendy
Charlotte and Jonah all made it out of
season three alive as per usual the
people around them were not also lucky
the shocking death in the final moments
of season 3 was the cartel lawyer Helen
Pierce
she had relocated to Osage Beach for the
summer after the casino got up and
running during the season a power
struggle between the birds and Helens
started to develop and in the end their
boss Omar Navarro decided that the birds
were more valuable to his operation he
had Helen executed in front of Marty and
Wendy saying today is our beginning
before embracing the blood south couple
who were still shocked by what they just
witnessed as shocking as that might have
been in the moment it wasn't the most
impactful death that the bird family
experienced the loss of Wendy's brother
Ben hits a lot closer to home and that's
the first big question that I have how
will Ben's death affect the bird family
Marty and Wendy started out season 3 at
odds with each other
after pulling off the near impossible
feat of opening the casino Marty and
Wendy had very different ideas about how
they should move forward Ben's arrival
on the scene didn't help the situation
and is mental illness started to cause
problems after he stopped taking his
medication he fell in love with Ruth
they started a relationship and in a
tragic twist her trying to help him by
getting him released from a mental
hospital set things in motion for his
downfall
I'm not gonna retell the whole story of
season 3 here the important thing for
this video is how his
death might affect everyone else going
forward I should say that I do believe
he's dead
I know we're trained to be skeptical if
we don't see the person actually die or
we don't see the body as proof but I
also believe that the story is best if
he is actually dead I don't think it
would be a good twist if they pull him
out later on and be like oh yeah
remember all that stuff that happened at
the end of season 3 it was all just the
fool you don't worry Ben is fine so yes
I do think he's dead I don't think
there's any chance he's gonna come back
it turns out to be a very difficult
situation for everyone that's involved
after arguing was Wendy about what
really happened
Ruth decided to leave the birds we saw
that Jonah was definitely struggling
with this and I thought the interesting
thing that came out of it was in the
immediate aftermath Marty was very
supportive to Wendy so the next big
question for me then would be will Marty
and Wendy work together as a team again
as tragic as Ben's death was will it
turn out to be the thing that brings
Marty and Wendy back together with Ruth
gone Marty will need someone to take her
place Wendy would be the most likely
candidate but it would require them to
work together in a way that they didn't
in season three and what about the rest
of the family who will all be coming to
terms with Ben's death first let's talk
about what the show is going to do with
Charlotte in season two she had this
close friendship with Wyatt and went to
a lawyer to try to get herself
emancipated in season three there was
very little mention of either of those
things and when we saw her she was
either working at the office or hanging
out with Helen's daughter Erin right
before Marty and Wendy left for Mexico
they gave her the keys to buddy's
mausoleum to coordinate the laundering
through the gamblers
well she get more involved with the
family business and are they just
dropping her friendship with Wyatt from
the story completely Jonah is an even
bigger question mark since we saw how
angry he was about Ben's death he first
turned his anger towards Helen but when
he went to visit her and threatened her
she made it clear that his parents
signed off on the murder we watched him
put the pieces together of their
involvement when he saw Ben's ashes
firing a shotgun blast through a window
in their home in a fit of rage he's
always been an odd character and he
doesn't really have any friends where
are they gonna take his story from here
and what about baby Zeke he was only a
part of their family for a short period
of time but none of the birds were happy
to see him end up with Darlene and
there's good reason for that
Wendy seemed determined to get him out
of that situation but her initial plan
to make Darlene look unfit didn't work
out things got crazy so fast with been
Helen and the cartel that there really
wasn't time to go back to it so going
into season four we have to wonder if
they will still try to get Zeke back
another character who I wonder about is
Rachel after everything that happened at
the blue cat and with her working for
agent petty
she did manage to make it out at least
as far as we know when we last saw her
Marty gave her a plane ticket to Miami
where he arranged the stay in the rehab
that he had prepaid for and he gave her
a down payment offering to buy her out
of the blue cat while all of this feels
like a fine way to write her out of the
story
the chemistry she developed with Marty
would make a return of the character
carry some weight have we seen the last
of Rachel and I guess by extension have
we seen the last of tuck we could ask
the same thing about two of the new
characters in this season Frank jr. and
Aaron Frank jr. wasn't my favorite
character he was annoying he was just
sort of there to cause problem in the
end Darlene took care of him she shot
off his manhood and that could be the
last we see of him and even though she
went to talk to his father and kind of
make him an offer we never saw him
explicitly agree to anything so there's
definitely a possibility that Frank jr.
might cause some problems going forward
Aaron is somewhat more interesting just
because of the stakes we would imagine
that she would go back to Chicago and
live with her father but I don't think
we could say for sure that the cartel
would be fine with her being out there
in the world she did give Jonah his
first kiss so he may stay in touch with
her and in that case if something were
to happen to her that might really push
him even further over the edge another
big question I have at the end of season
three is
what's gonna happen with the FBI we saw
them arrest Sam at the end of season
three Marty wasn't really that concerned
about that considering how nervous he
was about doing what he was doing it's a
little bit hard to believe that he won't
cave once they get him in an
interrogation room beyond that Maya
definitely knows that Marty and the
birds are connected to the Navarro
cartel to this point she hasn't been
able to prove it
Marty's been trying to get some leverage
against her which seems nearly
impossible because we know that she
isn't crooked we know that she's still
gonna be at the casino the warrant has
been extended so it'll be interesting to
see where things go
agent Evans should still be around as
well we last saw him working with Helen
who won't be returning so everything on
the FBI side of things is completely up
in the air one of the big character
ships in season three was Wyatt he now
seems to be all in on a relationship
with Darlene and I wonder what a future
for those two will turn out like Darlene
seems to be concerned was starting a
legacy getting the heroin business back
in full swing and creating a new crime
family that consists of locals with the
lang mores it makes you wonder if three
might play a more important role in
future seasons he was sort of sidelined
in season three it makes you wonder if
Darlene and Ruth would be able to work
together
Darlene hates the birds and I don't
think we should ever overlook that when
we think about her future plans for the
time being Ruth is also pretty firmly in
the anti bird camp but these are two
strong personalities we saw that Ruth is
absolutely capable in the work that she
did ver Marty but I'm not sure we could
say that Darlene will put up with the
same things that Marty would this whole
new alliance it just seems like there's
so many things that can go wrong with it
and it seems really unlikely that all of
these major players will make it out of
season four alive I also wonder if
someone will take Helens place Helen
essentially took the place of Dell who
was the go-between between Navarro and
the birds in the past the way things are
now it seems like Marty and Wendy are on
top of the food chain so would there
even be somebody else that what
come to take their place that makes me
wonder about Nelson who worked
side-by-side with Helen for so long well
he now works side-by-side with the birds
and if so how is someone like Jonah
gonna think about that also Ruth is
smart enough to know that she can't
really go after Nelson but his presence
should be particularly unsettling for
her he killed her father and her lover
so so seeing him around that could cause
issues but then again they might not
really cross paths
there's so many questions but I think
these are the biggest ones that are on
my mind right now
I'm really interested to see how Jonah
develops they always hinted that he was
sort of a strange character and Ben's
death really brought out the anger in
him at the end of the season at the same
time he's been somewhat accepting of
their situation he looks up to Marty at
least and he showed an interest in what
they actually do seeing the Lange Moors
on the same side as Darlene I mean
there's so much that could happen there
where things go also depends on how many
seasons we think there might be I know
that they've said in the past that they
thought about five it all depends on
where they land regardless of how many
seasons they do I think at this point we
can say that it's going to be crazy
wherever they go in season for the
cartel won't change they're not gonna
let up and that means that the pressure
will always be there so I'm gonna leave
it there those are my big questions tell
me in the comments what yours are what
you're hoping to see in season four what
are your favorite theories please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already I'm thinking about doing some
more ozark videos over the next couple
weeks thanks for watching I will talk to
you soon